I think we hate each other hate is a
strong word it's the right word but
still we have to convince them that we
know like no no no way
no you don't mean the temple connect
we're making plans for their newest
addition you're new but this baby has a
big plan
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy no that's
exactly the problem have you learned
anything I see we know what have you
learned about puppies good I'm sorry no
Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey be better
no I can't read what could say look Oh
it's like they're having a little
meeting last dessert so humiliating
you're going to write baby this job I
know how important this mission isn't
accompany me see ah poop duty I got a
deal with the K ID are you I'm on a
mission not enough love to go around my
job is to find out why they'll give me a
double espresso and see if there's
someplace around here with decent sushi
I kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now
oh yeah buddy look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice
the finals succeed with this mission I
will live here forever with you okay I
will help you but just to get rid of you
deal you come to Jersey no no you're
watching you two okay chew chew on that
how we can ask the guard I've never been
so humiliated in my life better bring my
I don't we're not Oh Wayne if you have
it done to me what's all the racket
maybe adorable oh I've got one for you
too what bummer
Green work the bus baby put that cookie
down
cookies offer closer
Oh
you